[Music]
is that far away boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
sake and very excited to be talking
about sustainable proteins to save the
world
we have Paul Shapiro joining us on the
show hello on my second on nice to see
you again super happy to have you back
on Paul was episode 14 old school old
school old school yeah one of the first
episodes that we did on at the time you
had just published the book clean meat
and we were just unpacking the
importance of it and it was such as
still one of my favorite books I loved
it so much it's very nice of you you
obviously don't read that much but I'm
glad I made it into your top tier it's
such a good book I highly recommend
everyone check it out and now Paul's
revisiting after a whole year of
advancing starting the better meat Co
starting a podcast getting married all
his cool stuff so I'm very excited to
unpack all this with you so Paul Shapiro
CEO and co-founder of the better Mikko
and he's the author of clean me how
growing meat without animals who
revolutionized dinner and the world he's
former VP at the Humane Society in the
United States and currently co-hosts the
business for good podcast and you can
find the links in the bio below to clean
meat book.com better meat co and
business for good podcast.com as well as
his Twitter so check those out everyone
let's jump into things with one of our
favorite questions to start things off
Paul let's do it what are your thoughts
on the direction of our world direction
of the world okay well if you are a
human being chances are that the world
is better today than nearly at any time
in the past I'm a firm believer in what
Steven Pinker is espousing that it's a
better time to be born than pretty much
any time in the past that even if you
are not living in the so-called first
world that your life is still much
better today than if you have been born
let's say a few hundred years ago much
greater chance of you eating a decent
life at least so as far as humanity is
concerned I feel
pretty good about where we are right now
however if you are pretty much any other
species on the planet things have gotten
a lot worse and so I am one who believes
that Homo sapiens are one animal on the
planet among millions and that we are
not the only animal on the planet who
matters in the same way that we used to
believe that the universe revolved
around us and Copernicus and Galileo
helped us to understand that we are not
the center of the physical universe well
today many people believe in for most of
human history people have believed that
we are the center of the moral universe
right that human beings are the only
species that matters and of course there
in times when it wasn't all humans it
was one race or one religion or one
gender or whatever but now today most
people who you or I might be in social
circles with would say humanity is what
matters that's the the moral center of
the universe whereas I think that other
animals matter too and we just haven't
yet expanded our circle of moral concern
out enough to actually account for that
and so while things have gone
indisputably better for human beings
they've gotten indisputably worse for
other animals not just the animals who
we are raising for food whose lives have
become ones pretty much deprivation and
misery but also for wildlife who we are
crowding out through our development
through our agriculture or through all
types of ways that we are crowding them
out and making it much more difficult
for them to eke out an existence and
through climate change which we are
causing as well so in fact if you watch
the really great new series I think our
planet on Netflix with David
Attenborough it's a really great look at
the beauty of nature and how much we are
doing to desecrate it so the state of
the world depends in my view where you
find yourself which species you find
yourself primarily speaking
yet the hefty dose of humility that is
so good and so needed that we are part
of a ecology that is much greater than
just ourselves and just even human race
right and in the past people thought
differently about this right like in the
past they would not have said it was all
humans they would certainly not have
thought foreigners they probably
wouldn't have thought about anybody
wasn't their race they would have
thought their grip their tribe whatever
their group was they thought was the
most important and today we generally
say welcome we don't actually like it of
course but we say all humans matter we
you know we do all types of things that
favor our own in-group of our other
groups but we always say often times
that all humans are important morally
speaking but there's a whole other world
of animals out there of species out
there and just because they aren't on
the throne like we are just because they
aren't the dominant species on the
planet like we are it doesn't mean that
they don't matter might doesn't make
right in that sense that yeah we are in
control of all of them I mean we can
wipe them out in a heartbeat right we
can do anything we want to them other
animals stand so powerless before us
that we can do virtually anything that
we want to them with nearly no
repercussions most of the time yeah
every once in a while animals will fight
back and attack us but it's very rare
most of the time we are obliterating
their homes or obliterating them we're
confining them we're enslaving them
we're doing all types of things that are
pretty unsavory and we do it because we
can get away with it not because it's
the right thing to do so yeah I am sad
to say that I think the ward is worse
for most animals today than in the past
well better for us whoa yeah what a way
to put it into perspective that our
lives have gone better in the meanwhile
we've made it harder for other species
to thrive on the planet
oh the hefty dose of humility is so
needed in the in the direction towards
us more sustainable ecology which we
actually talked about in a good amount
of detail and the first time we sat down
together on the episode and we talked a
lot about clean meat I want to spend a
good chunk of time talking to you about
what you've been doing in the last 14
months so the better meat Co has started
you got harried you started the business
for good podcast yeah so much good stuff
things happened yes yes so importantly I
did get married to Tony Okamoto who is a
guest on your show I don't know if
that'll come up before or after this
episode it just came up before
ok alright well she beat me to the punch
but yes I'm very you know Tony and I
work together for over two years and and
now are actually married and I know you
and I last time talked about whether we
thought that there was any life
elsewhere in the universe and I have a
great interest in astronomy and so
rather than getting the typical gold
ring I have a meteorite ring so as you
can see this here is a an actual
meteorite that was cruising through our
solar system for about four billion
years before smashing into what is now
no maybea and it was found a long time
ago by indigenous people in Namibia who
were using it for this is a huge it was
some like 35,000 kilograms or something
it's a really big meteorite and they
were using it to make weapons and all
types of things and then colonists came
and then they started you know they were
like hey where'd you what what rock is
that and they showed them and so they
started exporting parts of it and now no
movie it doesn't let you export any of
it anymore about what they did take you
can buy as jewelry and things like that
and so that's what this is it's a part
of the Gibeon meteorite that smashed
into Namibia whoa yeah that's been
wearing a meteorite yeah it's a wedding
ring that is literally out of this world
and yeah you know I'll tell you it was
pretty pretty interesting I didn't
really know much about like the
meteorite market but it's surprisingly
easy to get jewelry made out of these
extraterrestrial objects and these are
you know the oldest rocks in on the
planet literally these are the Ordos
rocks on the planet like you know
they've been formed four billion years
ago or so so yeah that's pretty home
yeah that you're wearing it now out of
this world yes buddy and then um you
guys started the podcast which I'm sure
we'll get to as well there's so much
good stuff there with business for good
and then also the better Miko has
started so what has what are what is
your thesis with the better Miko Andy's
sustainable proteins sure so there's a
major problem with animal agriculture
it's inefficient it's a leading cause of
greenhouse gas emissions it's a leading
cause of deforestation and land use and
antibiotic resistance animal welfare
concerns the list goes on and on and on
now there's lots of different responses
that you could have to this and in the
same way that lets say fossil fuels are
so problematic you want lots of
alternatives to them you want wind you
want solar you want geothermal and so on
but in the same way that you want lots
of alternatives to fossil fuels you also
want lots of alternatives to factory
farms so there are already companies
like beyond meat and impossible foods
that are making plant-based meats they
take plants like peas and soy and they
turn them into foods that look and taste
like animal meat that's awesome they're
having great success I really admire
what they're doing then you have
companies that are making Queen meat
which is real meat grown from animal
cells so they're not making alternatives
or substitutes to meat they're making
actual animal meat that they're growing
from animal cells
none of those companies have
commercialized their products yet but
you know people do think that they'll
probably do so within the next year or
two which would be quite amazing be
amazing to have the ability to eat real
meat slaughter free now
that would be a big advancement when it
happens but it's still you know between
the two of them Queen meat which is zero
percent of the market plant-based meat
which is still less than one percent of
the market you have about 99 percent
plus of meat still coming from animals
now think about that with regard to
let's say milk if you go to the milk
aisle today in your supermarket on
average
18% of that milk is plant-based well soy
almond coconut and so on whereas less
than 1% of the meat sold is coming from
plants this is huge room for growth in
this for both of them but especially in
the meat section and cheeses are also
starting to see probably less than 1%
right now ish yeah that's right
for sure but it is growing it is growing
and there's a there's a good joke about
this that a friend of mine Saif Tibbett
taught it to me which is did you hear
about the fire in the vegan cheese
factory the cheese still didn't melt
right but it's not really a good joke
anymore because it's not true anymore
ten years ago the vegan cheese of course
did not melt today it does thanks to
companies like daya and others so things
are changing in that respect now what
the better Miko does is it takes a
different approach rather than making
plant-based meats or Queen meats we are
formulating plant proteins in very
specific ways that enables them to be
used as an ingredient to put into meat
itself so we sell our plant-based
proteins to meet users for them to blend
into their ground meat so they can use a
lot less meat and I'll give you example
almond so imagine the following scenario
imagine that there is a corporate
cafeteria let's say in Cincinnati and
they are serving pork sausages now
imagine that they decide that they're
going to offer vegan sausages right next
to the pork sausages and by some miracle
it's gonna be the same price it's never
happened but let's just saved by some
miracle it's the same exact price lunch
time comes employees start filing in
what percentage of the people who would
have purchased the pork sausage do you
think are going to switch purposefully
to the vegan sausage
yeah I know from your facial expression
it's not looking good right 10 first
time sure so that would be an amazing
outcome I mean keep in mind plant-based
meat is still less than 1% of the total
market but sure let's say it's 10
percent that would be amazing that would
be fantastic will be the biggest success
to cause a 10% reduction in pork sausage
and switching to vegan what we do is we
enable that cafeteria to reduce their
consumption or selling of pork but not
by 10% but let's say by 30 to 50 percent
by blending our plant-based proteins
directly into the sausage and that way
nobody is even going to make a different
decision so the reality is that there is
a small percentage of people are going
to stop eating meat altogether but most
people are going to continue eating meat
and in fact meat consumption in the u.s.
is increasing right now and it's
increasing in places like China and
India and Brazil of the biggest
populations so if people are eating more
meat today than ever before in all of
human history what ways can we actually
cause a reduction that does not
necessitate conscious consumer behavior
change and that's what we're doing is
that we saw an ingredient that enables
people using meat to use a lot less meat
and people who are ordering that default
product that 9 out of 10 or plus people
are gonna be consuming they will get
less meat with it it's almost it's it's
in some ways similar not a perfect
analogy but it's in some ways similar to
when somebody puts gas in their car it's
no longer all fossil fuels a portion of
it maybe 15 percent is blended with
ethanol and there's all types of debate
about whether that's good or not but you
know it is it is that you are buying
less oil essentially and you don't even
think about it you don't even
contemplate that it's in there you just
do it and the same is so with what we're
doing that people who do what most
people do which is to continue to buy
meat will simply get less meat as a
result ok so such an interesting way to
to to put in sustainable proteins into
the existing meat consumption economy
yeah and and if it's ok so let's let's
break this down so you make sustainable
protein
yourselves with the better Miko yeah you
sell those sustainable proteins to
already meat producing companies pork
chicken beef etc that's right and then
they take your sustainable proteins and
they blend them into the beef let's say
that they already have and then they're
able to make their it that way they have
more of the beef that they initially
started with and then there that that
amount it's displaced so if an original
sausage like a pork sausage and your
cafeteria example had a hundred percent
pork in it now it only has somewhere
between thirty to seventy percent so
yeah it'd be like 50 sorry 50 to 70
percent pork that's right so 30 to 50
percent is your sustainable protein yeah
okay and that's how you decrease the
amount of meat that were consuming
through making sustainable proteins and
putting it into the existing meat
economy yeah that's exactly right and so
this has the effect of making the meat
much more sustainable but also by it
makes it healthier so we're reducing
saturated fat reducing cholesterol
reducing total calories all while making
the better choice the easier choice so
that you want to make doing the right
thing easier for people to do you don't
want to have to make them do something
that's they perceive as difficult and in
this case it doesn't involve behavior
change at all they can simply by what
they've been buying which is what most
people do and they will get a better
product better for the planet and better
for them
now it doesn't displace the need for
plant-based meats or for Queen me it's
just another complimentary strategy to
actually in the near term help reduce
demand for me and in the case that you
were just mentioning on unbe food would
mean that they would be able to use
fewer cows yeah they wouldn't need to
raise and Co as many cows because they
would be blending this product in and
now of course when people hear about
this
I mean sometimes people start thinking
about the f-word right they're like this
is a filler but indeed this isn't a
filler this is something that enhances
the product it makes it actually better
by definition a filler is something
that's like a carbohydrate based thing
like a bread crumb or cellulose that
is just bulking it up without doing
anything for nutrition our product is a
protein base so it roughly maintains the
amount of protein in the product while
at the same time helping them reduce
saturated fat and cholesterol in total
calories in making the product better in
a whole host of other ways so our
product is certainly far from the filler
it's really an enhancer and that we help
to make the meat better and then the
sustainable proteins that you were
listing earlier there's P proteins
there's one of the bean proteins there's
soy proteins so which ones is the sure
so yeah so if you think about let's say
the impossible burger that's a soy
protein base or if you think about the
beyond burger that's a pea protein base
we use in general for different products
we might use wheat as a base for one soy
as a base for another lentils or oats as
a base for some others lupine as a base
for some so there's a whole variety of
plant proteins out there that you can
use and our food scientist and our
microbiologist helped to formulate
products that meets that application so
it might be good in a chicken nugget is
going to be different than a pork
sausage it's gonna be different than a
meatball is different from a burger and
so we use a variety of these different
plant proteins in various combinations
in order to make a product that really
enhances the taste and texture of the
meat when people eat it okay okay and
this makes sense of course the different
sustainable proteins per each individual
use case in meat and then you started
listing off how this is we're out we're
using less meat actual meat in this
process which is excellent at the same
time we how is it if we blend the P
proteins with for whatever the
processing of protein is with the meat
how do you you were listing off some of
the benefits do we feel as though these
are good longitudinally for us to be
able to consume them together we think
this is good yeah so first and foremost
it does make it healthier I mean it
really improves the Nutritionals on the
product but it also has other benefits
so not just sustainability but one
poultry company
a focus group with their customers with
our product they serve them blind
taste-test to their own products which
are 100% chicken - the breading on the
outside and then they serve them blended
so 2/3 their product 1/3 our product and
what they found was that 60% of the
consumers could not tell any difference
at all 30% preferred the blended version
and 10% preferred the solely meat
version so 90% of people said either no
difference or actually is better and
imagine that that you could cut down on
the number of birds who are being
confined and and raised for food by a
third with that with 90% of people
saying no difference or better I mean
that'd be massive you know there's 9
billion chickens raised for food in the
United States each year imagine if a
third of them were displaced now of
course this only works on a ground meat
application so imagine even if half a
billion could be replaced I mean what a
legacy - to help prevent half a billion
birds from undergoing the type of
processes that are used in today's
animal agribusiness sector I would be
very pleased to accomplish that that's
great that you had that taste test with
such solid results - and so it does seem
then to make sense to want to add
sustainable proteins into the existing
meat mix meat industry to make it so
that we use less of the product we
slaughter less of the animals ok ok and
then so the better Mikko now is a bit
over a year now of being CEO and
co-founder of this you gave us the
example of doing a with the with the
chicken come with the juice chicken
company that's that's adding sustainable
protein was that calf was that cafeteria
example at the pork sausage is another
one that's that's the I serrano at the
chicken yeah it came through that's
great what what what are the other
industry examples where you're applied
sure so we can go into burgers or hot
dogs or sausages
meatballs or chicken nuggets we work
really well especially in dumplings and
in Chile and in some of these you can
use our product even at a hundred
percent without really noticing any
difference and no meat whatsoever
but we think that there's a real benefit
for companies that are serving meat to
blend us in because they can essentially
add something that makes their products
better in numerous ways and it's not
going to appeal just to the vegetarians
but rather the nine out of ten people
who are going to continue eating meat
and ordering meat can end up using those
so imagine that you're a dumpling
manufacturer and let's say you have a
vegetable line of dumplings in a pork
line and a beef line of dumplings
probably around five or ten percent of
your customers are buying the vegetable
dumplings but quite closer to 90 percent
are buying some type of a meat based
dumpling well it's important to have
that vegetable based dumpling but
imagine if you can replace half the meat
in the other ones with our product I
mean you would have a far better
advancement in terms of meat reduction
than you would by having you know a
doubling of the demand for the vegetable
one so that's what we help them do and
then how would I as a dumpling
manufacturer do I just reach out to the
bettor meat co and then yes guys like do
an independent consultation with me with
your food scientists and that's right so
we would do is come to you and do a demo
for you we make a product for you that
let's say was fifty percent of your meat
and fifty percent of our meat and let
you taste it see what you think and
tasting is believing you can do taste
test with your own staff with your own
customers and check it out and see you
know we're on it we're online at better
meat Co get in touch with us and we have
products for beef we have products to
enhance pork to enhance chicken and so
on and we would love to work with
anybody who is interested in using more
sustainable proteins whoa okay cool so
then as Jackie said tastings believing
so they can actually have the process of
seeing these results as well okay okay
another another thought about this was
that within within this this these
companies that are testing the
the alternatives of the sustainable
proteins or what is the approximate
amount of saving that they're making
that yeah teach us about that process to
like what is you guys are manufacturing
this in bulk right and then they're
adding they're blending it yep okay and
they're saving money because they're not
using that additional cost in meat so
there's a savings there yeah we aim to
be cost competitive with the meat that
we're displacing so on beef and pork
it's easier for us to do that on chicken
chicken at the commodity level is really
cheap we do think that we can get there
but we aren't always necessarily cheaper
on that front but on beef and pork it's
easier for us to compete on cost but we
are creating a product that makes their
meat better so even if they're gonna pay
a little bit more in that case we
believe that the product is actually a
better product and they they would be
happy to do that
now of course cost is oftentimes king
along with taste and we have to bring
our prices down for for those really
inexpensive meats and we are getting
there we really are making a lot of
progress right now and we're in fact
scaling up by building a production
facility in Woodland California that'll
allow us to meet that goal okay so the
production facility is going up it's
scaling up to meet these goals of cost
tastes then what do they have to label
the product
do they have to label the product and
say that it has sustainable protein in
it or can they just say it's so well you
certainly have to include it on the
ingredient list but there are some
standards of identity that USDA has so
for example when it comes to a hamburger
you can't call it a hamburger if it has
anything other than beef in it however
they take as an example sonic the fast
food chain they make a blended burger if
that's 25% mushrooms 75% beef they can't
call it a hamburger so they call it the
Sonic slinger it looks like a hamburger
it's on the burger menu it's called a
sonic slinger nobody thinks twice about
it interesting so there are ways to get
around
that type of a problem by not using the
prohibited terminology but for other
products there aren't necessarily
standards of identity at all and so it's
less of a concern but the key is that as
long as you're wasting it on the
ingredients as something then it you
shouldn't have that concern you
shouldn't have any concern about it and
then so it would be like literally the
packaging of that frozen chicken nugget
would say that it has P protein as one
of the ingredients that's exactly right
and I think that this product works best
is a stealth health product so I'll give
you an example many of the health health
yep so a popular phrase in the public
health community because if you think
about it I'll give you an example on
canned soups a lot of the can soup
manufacturers in recent years have been
reducing their sodium count people were
very concerned about it Michelle Obama
was very concerned about it for example
and so companies at Campbell's and
others started reducing the amount of
sodium very slowly in their canned soups
but they didn't put it on the label less
sodium healthier because people hear
less sodium the thing it means less
flavor right and so that actually
depresses price that price it depresses
demand and the same is so when you label
foods low fat or less fat or whatever
people think less flat they think the
best flavor and so our product actually
does enhance the flavor while reducing
the total saturated fat but it's not the
best thing to advertise on because you
lose people you know indulgence is what
people want they don't want restriction
and so for us to market this as a health
product might appeal to some people
but for the everyday masses of meat
eaters out there it's not that appealing
so yeah Stealth health I think is a
better way to go that's such an
interesting concept ik motto phrase
Stealth health yep
and so then so then the the the
packaging can actually say things that
it can potentially say more flavoring ya
know or you can say boost it with plant
protein people are really unless people
are really into plant protein these days
where is it with yeah yeah yeah that's
what we're done I like that a lot
boosted with Wow okay in the mid
of the people that are working with you
right now our our or manufacturers of
the large-scale meet yes that's right
and restaurants and individual
restaurants can also yeah work with you
yeah they'll purchase from us and add us
let's say to their dumplings as an
example okay okay okay and then the big
cafeterias is also interesting because
they have like you know stop about tens
of thousands sometimes of people that
are eating there yeah so we also do them
right now but we would like to yeah
and I saw you like post about some of
the like Cargill's making massive
advances and yeah lean meat and
sustainable protein so they could be an
interesting one yeah yeah for sure we
would be quite honored to work with them
nice ok cool it's good - it's good to
know that we can you know push
connections as they come up because I
think that's a really good way to get to
scale fastest through the corporate
cafeterias as well yeah I totally agree
with you yeah yeah ok the better meiko's
so cool I'm glad that you were able to
break that down for us so you've been
spending the last year-plus on that
let's talk about in the first time that
we sat down together we spent a lot of
time unpacking clean meat and just you
know you've gave them given us little
bits and pieces it throughout the
conversation about the sustainability
the environment the humanity with the
animals and they're conscious so you've
been kind of listing off these things I
want to know in 2018 after we sat down
together in March it was there was a
slew of funding that went to clean me
companies as well as 2019 this be this
year as well again a massive amount of
funding so yeah what's been the update
in the last 14 months on the clean meat
industry well first before I get there
once they say yes we did sit down th at
about in a March but you may remember
that we also got together at your home
prior yes and you gave me some really
helpful feedback on a talk that I was
going to give your TEDx talk yeah and I
implemented
your suggestions and you may remember
that you thought that the beginning was
too lengthy it took me too long to get
to the main like meat of the talk so to
speak and I agreed and so I slashed a
lot of it and cut it down I kind of wish
I would have slashed more which you were
still pressing me to do but your
feedback on it was very helpful and I
implemented it I'm grateful and my only
regret is that I didn't implement more
fit back then but it was a it was a good
talk and I'm glad that was at South Lake
Tahoe it was good memory and you had the
big harping on so Paul brought a harp is
a real six foot long harp in like an
actual heart pain that I've been used
and it was beautiful when you told me
this because then I realized how much
emotional connection people were going
to have to you bring the harpoon out
because people were using that for
weight for killing whales for the oil
right yeah yeah right the basic word
blubber yeah yeah the basic premise is
that you know we everyone used to have
whale oil lamps at home and whaling was
a taking a really serious toll on whale
populations in the 19th century there
are even letters to the editor in
newspapers back then from people
pleading to save the whales and these
weren't modern-day environmentalists
these are you know 19th century
pre-civil war Americans writing letters
to the editor pleading to spare the
whales and they also eventually were not
really liberated from harpoons by humane
sentiment or by sustainability concerns
they were liberated because the
invention of kerosene and we switched
over pretty rapidly to a cleaner more
efficient more affordable method of
lighting our homes and similarly it may
be so that farm animals the animals who
we confined on factory farms by the
billions may not be freed by humane
sentiment or sustainability concerns but
it may be that there are technological
advancements either in plant-based meat
and or in queen' meat that could render
their exploitation as obsolete as a
whaling ship is today and so that's the
point I was making with that harpoon
that maybe one day and the
not-too-distant future we may think of a
slaughterhouse as archaic as we do a
harpoon we may we need to stay on this
point just for another mole
longer because we speak about this so
much on the show about creating things
that obsolete render the old stuff
obsolete and update the new code to go
around trying to plead with people to
make a change versus making something
that is so much better than what the
existing code is yeah yeah I mean think
about it like we don't exploit carrier
pigeons anymore not because people cared
about pigeons but we had better ways to
send our letters we don't exploit horses
in our city streets anymore not because
people necessarily felt bad for the
horses but because Henry Ford invented a
much better way that of transporting
ourselves that rendered the exploitation
of horses totally obsolete in fact
really interestingly I was reading an
interview with susan b anthony the famed
women's rights advocate from the very
last decade of her life is in the 1890s
and she asserted that she thought that
the bicycle had done more to advance
women's interests than the women's
rights movement had whoa and that's a
pretty amazing statement to make and the
basic point was like in the 1880s there
been bicycles for decades for Daredevils
and circus acts and so on but the
so-called safety bicycle was invented in
the 1880s and it gave women a way to get
out of their house to leave their house
to not be dependent on the men in their
lives to take them anywhere and enable
them to organize that enabled them to
enter the workforce more easily and made
them enable and enable them to basically
lead less domestic lives
Wow and so she thought like the bike
which even the inventor had like I'm
sure did not intend for this consequence
to happen in the same way Henry Ford
didn't care about horses but sometimes
there are technological advancements
that help to solve moral problems that
up solve social problems where their
inventors couldn't have been envisioned
it now it can work the other way too you
can have technologies that make matters
much worse
for example the cotton gin made slavery
much more economically lucrative to the
south so in fact people argue that the
cotton gin led to the civil war because
it made the south
cling on to slavery much more when it
was that much more economically
important so technology it's like a
knife you can be used to you know cure
somebody with a surgery or can be used
to stab somebody either way technology
can
helped exacerbate social problems or
solve them but I believe that the
problem of animal agriculture is not
going to be solved without technology
without new types of food science
advancements that are going to enable us
to continue to eat the foods that we
love eating without having so many
negative side effects yes yes yes ok so
this is one of the main thesis is in the
book is that there's just so much crazy
that just tent there's only tens of
thousands of like lions and penguins but
there's billions of cows and chickens
and this like and you were speaking
about this earlier like their lives did
not get better those are our lives did
get better and we're gonna obsolete the
old code the old mental maps of the
world by making this making clean meat
cost less than then slaughtering animals
as well as make it potentially even
enhance us as well so there's so many
cool things with these like a micro
groove reactors bio reactors and stuff
but yeah give us the you know in the
last 14 months yeah what has like really
been peaking your interest in the space
so when I published this book in January
2018 there were maybe about half a dozen
companies in the world that existed to
advance to produce real meat without
having to raise them slaughter animals
now there are about 30 of them and
before there was very little investment
very little investment now you have
major investments I mean just this just
this week the Israeli startup all the
farms announced that it raised twelve
million u.s. dollars including from
Cargill one of the largest beef
producers on the planet invested in
growing beef without cows so when you
have Tyson Foods investing in these
companies and Cargill investing in them
and you're seeing tens of millions of
dollars now going in and even yolk meats
that one of the first Queen Meat Company
and Singapore just announced that they
raised 4.6 million dollars from their
seed round just their seed round and you
see that investors are getting
increasingly hungry for these type of
alternative proteins and there's a lot
going into it of course again
stick none of it not one ounce has ever
been sold so you need to temper our
expectations by saying like not only is
it up and so there's not one government
on the planet that has allowed its sale
yet even if they could compete on cost
so there's still a long way to go but
the potential is vast I mean I like in
it in some ways to the the digital
photography revolution the very
beginning you know for a long time we
only had photos that we printed out from
gelatin film and you ain't do a darkroom
and I mean I actually remember I
remember when I was like I think in
early high school and one our photo came
out and I was like wow I couldn't
believe we were getting out our photos
within one hour
it's amazing one hour and now imagine if
it took one minute imagine if your phone
took one minute to give your photo
I mean Apple stock would go down the
tubes if they took one minute to get
your photo I mean even if it was two
seconds you'd be upset actually so you
know but back then it was really hard to
imagine that and yet it's the same thing
it's still a photograph right like it's
still a picture of what you press the
button of like that you captured
something from life and so functionally
it is pretty much the same thing except
it's just vastly better in innumerable
ways and that's why very few people even
have cameras that use gelatin film
anymore there aren't that many one-hour
photo shops left around and similarly we
may come to think of the idea of raising
animals for food and slaughtering them
for food in the way that we think of
gelatin film that's the way we used to
do it but now we have much better ways
to get the same result we can still have
me it still enjoy me it's just that you
don't have to do all of the inconvenient
things that you used to have to do to
get it and that's the promise of
cellular agriculture to be able to
produce the same foods that we love with
vastly fewer resources and fewer
externalities so you don't have all of
the food safety problems all the animal
cruelty problems all the greenhouse gas
emissions and so on and so on down the
line these problems that most people are
familiar with now regarding animal
agriculture
yeah this this the hedonic adaptation
are you were just speaking about was
very interesting how we share
transitioned from having you know the
dial-up and the one-hour phone photo
development to we can't even take three
seconds to let us something load yeah so
he got we adapted crazily fast the
baseline increased and so oh yeah it's
gonna increase again with clean meat you
know we we say a lot on the show that
fifty years down the line the kids are
gonna be like it we can't believe you
were slaughtering billions of animals
yeah on the plot on the planet I want
you to speak about this it used to be so
in January 2018 was six companies in now
in May 2009 teen were up to thirty
companies yeah and even Singapore cheok
meets the Singapore uh what's the
Israeli one again alala Aleph olive yeah
what is olive because shiok is doing
seafood as well right yes so she o
commits and shook in in Malaysia means
kind of like cool or fantastic it's like
street slang for cool or fantastic I'll
with farms olive is the first letter in
the Hebrew alphabet
I left that vet so cough is is the first
letter in their alphabet but they were
primarily working on beef yeah oh great
to war more interest in this in the
space twelve million you said they just
raised twelve million dollars yeah
already amazed how these in the seed
round first shock was four point six
yeah now keep in mind at the same time
I mean impossible foods this past week
announced that they just raised another
three hundred million bringing them to
like three-quarters of a billion dollars
raised so far so the plant-based meat
space is vastly far ahead and possible
raise 300 million dollars recently this
past week yeah week yeah and that's on
top of the four hundred that they had
already raised prior prior to that so
they're valued at over billion two
billion yeah - I think is where they're
at
and do we know how much they move
impossible foods burgers do we know how
many they move every single like month
or I don't know I don't know if they've
publicized that but they did just
announce a joint partnership with Burger
King so that was huge the whopper yes so
awesome a whopper yeah you know it's
actually in st. Louis on a layover the
other day and I said which is the first
city that they rolled it out in and I
really wanted to leave the airport to go
try it and I was like weighing the
chance to like be a part of history you
know trying the impossible whopper in
the very first city that it rolled out
in versus the hassle of like moving the
airport and then going back through
security and possibly missing my flight
and all this and so I didn't do it which
I kind of regret cause my flight got the
way it did so I could have made it
definitely but anyway I do look forward
to it I have enjoyed greatly going to
Carl's jr. and getting leid beyond
burger from there which is quite fun
beyond burgers and Carl's jr. roll down
Carl's jr. and possible foods rolled out
in in the Burger King yeah I want you to
speak to this I think this is very
important yes a few my understanding is
that the impossible burger will cost $1
more than the whopper then the
impossible whopper will be $1 more than
a conventional whopper and that's for
now yes that's pretty good $1 more
that's a scientist yeah Wow yes I you
know there is a funny thought where you
know you often times see like especially
here in San Francisco you see bumper
stickers no farms no food well
considering how integral scientists have
become in feeding us I think we should
make bumpers servers ain't no scientists
no food no food that's a good one you
know that's the truth that is the truth
it's not that the other one isn't also
true but it is it's just also true that
we should be grateful for scientists I
think another one of the images that's
really good for this is when you see the
person that was that's that's juggling
plates on the stage in front of
thousands of people and then which you
don't see is all the steps leading up to
the stage where there's all the broken
plates
and so then that's very true for
basically anything that people build as
artists or entrepreneurs or scientists
and like what's currently being done oh
it's only a dollar more Wow and soon
it'll be equivalent and then less and
yeah and then the taste will be
completely indistinguishable I want you
to speak to this quick these timelines
okay
the investment that investments that are
being made and clean meat companies it's
just this is still the nascent period
that's so true so please get your
friends your families your co-workers
social media give people involved it's
wanting to put in money apparently Indy
bio thinks this is a hundred trillion
dollar opportunity in the last couple of
of the next century it's gonna be just a
hundred the bio econ the bio
opportunities are massive but
agriculture and food specifically it's
like multi trillion so you can get in
early still today by putting money in
and so it's so early it's so early
I mean twelve million dollars it sounds
a lot to mere mortals like us but in the
world of the meets business it's it's
nothing it's a tiny little sliver
I mean what's really needed to make
clean me something that is scalable and
is gonna be cost competitive is orders
of magnitude more than that and they're
the companies that are going to succeed
might not even exist yet like you could
be the early investor in the one that's
actually going to succeed I mean look at
just there's so many examples of this
from looking at like well anyway there's
lots of there's lots of examples of
companies that were not the first to
market but which ended up becoming
little do the market leaders that's
right but point is there are so many
opportunities to get involved in this
space Queen Mead is just one there is
also Queen love their companies eggs
milk there's companies that are making
even spider silk out through through a
cellular agriculture there's companies
doing plant based meats plant-based
seafood meat it meat enhancement like
what better meat Co is doing so there's
a whole range of opportunities to try to
use business to solve these problems the
reality is is that the governments of
the world so far have not come close to
solving the most pressing problem that
we face which is how we feed ourselves
sustainably
at the root of our public health crises
are climate change crisis food
insecurity like the world is only
getting smaller and smaller you know
when we think about humanity increasing
our numbers we're at seven point eight
billion people today but by 2050 it's
gonna be closer to 10 billion people the
planets not getting bigger our footprint
on it is getting bigger we're not gonna
be farming Mars we're not gonna be
farming the moon we only have this
planet and well I hope we do eventually
get to Mars the bottleneck is now here
yeah and if we don't get extremely more
efficient about how we feed ourselves
we're not going to even have a choice
excuse me we're not gonna have a chance
to be able to do things like colonize
other celestial bodies so we won't
survive ourselves and so because the
governments have not implemented
policies that are gonna solve this
businesses are now taking up the mantle
and they are creating solutions like the
time yes that are described in this book
like the type of solutions we've been
talking about during this chat yes yes
the another critical piece to this is
that you're describing you know
companies like Michael works doing
mycelium production for leathers for
structural materials there's so many
interesting ways of course egg whites
and and other dairy products cheeses and
whatnot so there's there's this is now
taking foot in the clothes that we wear
how can they be made what what what does
biology know that we don't know what are
the billions of years of evolution of
things like mycelium and bacteria
how can they be potentially even
genetically engineered to do things like
sequester carbon or cat or eat plastics
there's all different kinds of crazy
things you know it's just reading an
article it's so interesting you
mentioned the sound this is just reading
an article the other day about how
there's not one but two fungal species
that we know can digest plastic which is
incredible to me because think about
people say well project isn't
biodegradable we have thousands of
thousand billions of tons probably a
plastic out there in the environment and
we don't know what to do with it and we
keep producing more of it well we need
to stop producing non biodegradable
plastic but what if we could let's say
create let's say there's
buddy out there here's a company idea
for you start a company that uses these
species of fungus to ferment plastics
and actually biodegrade them and create
maybe something usable like some soil or
may I don't know what they excrete once
they digested but the questions yeah
yeah I don't know what it is I am NOT a
mycologist but if you could use certain
fungal species to actually know or if
presuming that what they use to
presuming what they use to digest it as
an enzyme you could find a way to
synthesize that particular enzyme and
then mass-produce it and get rid of this
plastic you know pray you know create
contracts with municipalities to take
their plastic from them digest it and
break it down and have make something
useful out of it in the same way that
there are carbon capture companies now
that are trying to take co2 out of that
mecir and sell it for biofuels or for
other things that actually are useful
for the world why not make plastic be
useful as well our ignorance we need a
hefty dose of humility because then we
can actually get to the solutions more
effectively we can tap into the
understanding of biology to tackle these
things yeah I often say that the only
thing that exceeds our arrogance is our
ignorance yeah
because we believe ourselves to be so
smart in fact we call ourselves Homo
sapiens which means you know the wise
human right and of course that's what we
call ourselves that's not what was just
ordained to be called we believed that
but that's our own arrogance really and
actually you know to Ryan see of a quote
from Darwin it's a paraphrase sadly I
don't have it exact but he said it's
something like ignorance and stills
confidence more than knowledge does oh
that's good too good one yeah yeah yeah
and so which is true like wait ignorance
instills confidence but the more you
know the more you realize you don't know
you don't know yeah yeah yeah yeah
so yeah the thing I know is I know
nothing yes the great paradox yes so
yeah so anyway look up the quarter say
ignorant nothing instills yes ignorance
more frequently begets confidence than
does knowledge it is those who know
little and not those who know much whose
so positively assert that this or that
problem will never be solved by vastly
more profound than my paraphrase
obviously thanks for opposed no I didn't
it by heart okay just a couple thoughts
on the way out I want to I want to get
your take on this quake um you you and
Tony started the business for good
podcast you are you've been mentioning
it so much throughout this conversation
that we're tackling some of the biggest
challenges were prioritizing
ecology were prioritizing solving these
challenges and so teach us about these
guests that you've been having every two
weeks on the business of a good podcast
why you did it yeah sure so the purpose
of this podcast is to spotlight
companies that are using the power of
Commerce to make the world a better
place I really believe that many of the
most pressing challenges that we face as
a species will be solved by innovation
and through technological advancements
oftentimes and so we interview titans of
industry and small-scale entrepreneurs
who are starting companies to try to
solve real pressing problems sure these
folks would like to make money but
that's not the purpose of what they're
doing
yes you know john mackey who was a guest
of ours the CEO of Whole Foods there's a
really great analogy where he talks
about how if your body makes red blood
cells if you don't make red blood cells
you will die but that's not the purpose
your purpose of your body is not to make
red blood cells it's the purpose for
your body to do whatever you deem it is
whatever meaning you give your life
that's your purpose that's what you're
gonna pursue
well the same is so with the business
businesses have to make money without
making money they will die but that's
not the purpose of the business
businesses that are truly conscious
about their purpose know that making
money is not their ultimate aim it's a
certainly an important part of what they
do it's a side effect of what they do
but they're trying to for example make
organize all of the world's information
for us like Google or promote public
health like John Mackey would say that
Whole Foods is do
or be the most consumer friendly company
on the face of the planet like Amazon
says right so they have their own
purpose well think about then a purpose
like like Lynn Grove which is a company
here in San Francisco Jojo yeah shout
out to Joe who is on our podcast they
are making tree free wood they're making
products that I act like wood and making
guitars out of them and so on that don't
involve cutting down trees chairs - yeah
yeah i sat in their chairs really cool
yeah yeah it's pretty awesome I would
like to have one of those chairs what a
Stata Center was like the Tesla chairs
yeah yeah this wooden chair was made
without wood yeah yeah exactly it's a
cool story or if you think about people
like Shia meets like Sandhya who we had
on the podcast she's a PhD biologist who
is now making shrimp without having to
raishin she's actually growing shrimp
shrimp cells and there's many other
companies so appeal Sciences is another
one a p/e or a PE EE L appeal where they
have created an organic basically a film
that goes on top of produce that makes
it last for twice as long well and so
think about how that can affect food
waste if your produce lasted twice as
long as it does and really coulis it
actually makes it not just last longer
but be riped longer so if you think
about like an avocado where the avocado
like the period the window of ripeness
it's like that you know that you miss it
you're done you're a goner whereas they
double the length of the ripe window as
well so that it lasts longer and it
makes it it makes it better so yeah so
we should I mean if all of akhadas were
how to peel applied to them like thing
about what a great world that would be
would be a much better world so that
wasn't another example of a company or
we had on Prince Khalid who is a Saudi
Arabian Prince and he's a venture
capitalist who invest in clean energy
and alternative proteins we had on
McDonald's vice president to talk about
their decisions from when in like the
nineteen
Blasi was in the 1980s and they got rid
of styrofoam in favor of plastics be
excused me in favor of paper or with
some of their other sustainability
initiatives they've done we had on a
Seth Goldman the CEO of Honest Tea we
wanted to try to create less sweet
products to reduce the number of sugar
calories in Americans diets and
upselling it to cook and now you know
they're in the Happy Meal I mean it's
incredible though
yeah something and he's now the
executive chairman of beyond me
interestingly enough whoa
so yep so you know we have on the folks
who have been really successful
businesspeople and people who are just
you know real nascent entry into the
business world who are trying to create
new products and new companies that can
solve pressing problems and so that's
the whole premise of the show and it's a
lot of fun I've learned a lot and I've
heard from a number of people who have
either joined startups or have started
their own companies now because they've
been inspired by listening who've said
yeah I want to start a company I hope
that somebody who taught Matt this
fungal company for plastic I hope that
somebody would do that I hope somebody
takes that idea yeah yeah I'm happy that
you've started the show cuz now you get
that what you just said there about you
get to sit down with these leaders and
you have conversations that are then
recorded and get to inspire and engage
other people and you're like damn this
is fun stuff you get alert yeah I'm
learning so much from it I really do and
you know there's my knowledge prior to
doing it was largely in the food space
but we've interviewed a lot of people
who are doing really cool things outside
of food that are really doing tremendous
things to solve problems one of my
favorite interviews actually was a guy
father Greg Boyle who is a priest down
in LA and he thought that gang members
had really bad lives and he wanted to
find ways to help them reenter society
so he started homeboy industries and he
created all these businesses that just
hire like ex-offenders and he gets jobs
for people he creates businesses for the
purpose of hiring ex-offenders to give
them a way out of the gang life so and
you know what a great thing I mean
everybody deserves second chances you
know even people who have murdered
somebody if they come out and they want
to reenter society we should let them
re-enter and
you know be actually a positive role in
society have a productive job and bake
bread for somebody that's one of their
companies it's a homeboy bakeries so
yeah you know I'm a big I'm a big fan of
what he is doing by giving people second
chances I love it and I love listening
to to the podcast definitely go check it
out everyone business for good
dot business for good podcast.com yeah
is the full-length this is for good
podcast calm and then let's ask the
couple quick questions on the way out
all right okay we have I'm pretty sure
we asked at least a couple of these the
first time I sat down tequila be
interesting to see if you've changed
yeah thoughts on the answers
yeah maybe a new evidence has arisen
that is worth waiting to reconsider
yeah what is the new evidence on the
first one are we alone in the cosmos
you know I'm distressed that it's
becoming increasingly in vogue to think
that we might be alone I think that
since the last time that we talked
there have been there's a study on the
Drake Equation that was suggesting well
actually it looks like we may be more
likely to be alone it looks like there
might actually be like a great filter
that prevents life and I am not sold on
this and a lot of smart people are but I
think that every time Homo sapiens have
believed that we are special we have
been knocked off of our throne we
thought we were the only animal that
used tools we thought we're the only
animal with language we thought we were
the only animal with a set of morality
or ethics and all these things have been
disproven and I just and I think it's
totally hubristic to declare that we are
alone it's a vast universe vast and
light that the the elements of life the
things that make up life are in
widespread abundance throughout life
throughout the universe and we know that
even in our own solar system on Europa
on Enceladus there are massive liquid
water oceans right now that have been
there for billions of years so you may
be these liquid water oceans have been
for billions of years and don't have
life in them possible but I wouldn't
mind going and checking it out going in
and seeing I have a friend Brian Anton's
who is working at NASA on these type of
missions to figure out like how could we
actually go to Europa and see because
it's like you know a number of
kilometers down is where the session is
is all ice on the outside and so you
know it's hard to get there it's not
like you can you know cut a hole and and
go down you have to drill a huge
distance Enceladus has the plumes that
we yes
yeah and Cassini actually captured some
of the plumes that came out of Enceladus
but the good news is that the ice on
both Enceladus and on Europa is moving
around and sometimes it breaks and you
can look on them and see photographs of
them that our probes have taken and see
that like lines where they've broken and
then shifted and so if you couldn't land
and go to somewhere where near where
brakes you know drop a camera down there
and see see if you find any fish down
there boom yeah it's hard to think of
something that would have a bigger
impact on how we see ourselves actly and
how humble we become from that yeah yeah
I hope that's true I mean it's you know
human arrogance is a persistent feature
of our operating system it seems but I
would like to believe that if we knew
that we were not as special as we think
that we are that there is life elsewhere
then maybe we would come to recognize a
humbler place in the cosmos for
ourselves and not think of ourselves as
tyrants and dominators of everything
that's around us but maybe we would say
maybe for example that the other animals
here on this planet don't exist merely
for us but rather exist with us maybe
our brethren who are existing on
Enceladus should they exist are also
just living here in the cosmos with us
none of us has to be born we arose
without any consent on our part and yet
here we are
meaning that might be true maybe we
if we came from somewhere beyond
playground earth to come into these
earth suits potentially I'm open to that
possibility I really am but we don't
know and I think it's important to have
a sense of humility about ourselves and
to remember that we are these frail
fallible little like hairless apes and
we have momentarily risen to be the
dominant species on our planet for the
time being let us not get drunk on our
own power let us not think that we
somehow are some you know fallen angel
we are just a risen ape and the reality
for us is that the better understanding
of our humble place in the cosmos that
we can assume I think the better off it
is not just for our fellow creatures on
this planet but for ourselves as well
because that type of an attitude that
places you on the throne and everyone
else at your feet yeah is a corrupting
at it totally totally well said the next
question is are we in a simulation mmm
evidence gets better yeah I saw lots of
people who are who have thought about it
more than I have and who are smarter
than I am but we've so they believe it's
like 99% like with right so I'm willing
to accept that it's true however it
changes nothing about what I would do
with my life
so the suffering here is still real I
believe that even if we're in a
simulation it is still bad for you to
get sick it is still bad for me to cut
your arm off it is still bad for you
know you to you know lose a loved one
that the suffering is still real and my
goal in life is to reduce as much
suffering as like him I want to promote
happiness and reduce suffering those are
the metrics by which I will measure the
the worth of my life really and
simulation or not I believe that
suffering is real and I believe that we
should reduce as much of it as possible
you're gonna keep leveling up and
achieving your goals but it very much so
could be that we are in the simulation
oh I I'm very open to that possibility
that we are in some type of either like
an ancestor simulation or or something
along that line yeah I mean who knows I
don't know I don't have any idea but I'm
willing to accept that it's true and I'm
willing to say it will change nothing
it's kind of like free will
I think logically speaking it seems
unlikely that we have it right I just I
can't imagine how it could be true but
it still doesn't change anything I'm not
gonna sit in bed and think I couldn't
have helped but to sit in bed all day
I'm going to get up and try to make the
world a better place so maybe I couldn't
help but to have done that I don't know
maybe my psychology led me to do that
but I believe that free will or no free
will
I will act the same way no matter what
and then our last question is what is
the most beautiful thing in the world oh
your last interviewee Tony Okamoto
obviously so yes I love my wife and I'm
very thrilled to be her husband I do
think that she's beautiful but for me to
be perfectly honest with you what when I
think of beauty in the world I think of
those who have power that are using
their power to help those who are less
fortunate than they are and so when I
see for example a soldier in a war zone
who is giving water to a stray dog or
when I see somebody in for example
Africa who is using their career to help
protect animals from being poached and
that speaks volumes about humanity's
capacity for good in the world it's not
solely that we are committing all this
cow s cruelty and doing horrible things
but that we can also display enormous
compassion an enormous kindness and we
can lead very selfless lives devoted to
the service of others especially those
who are less fortunate
and so it doesn't need to just be
animals it can be human beings or I mean
I think that's wonderful for people who
devote their lives to helping those
humans are less fortunate - but to me
seeing those who have power and could
use it for selfish purposes but instead
of using it for selfless purposes that's
real beauty it's a great one thank you
so much Paul Thank You Alan this has
been such a pleasurable yeah it is my
pleasure thank you thank you thank you
thank you we've had such a good
conversation for round two I've really
enjoyed it a lot Alan spent time super
fun super fun I want everyone to check
out this you know to have more
conversation sustainable proteins to
save the world thank you very much for
tuning in and talk to more people about
this give us your thoughts in the
comments below also go check out the
links below the clean meat book com read
that book share it with other people
also better meat co start talking more
people about that the business for good
podcast calm as well as Paul's Twitter
check out those links below talked to
more people about the climis revolution
talk to more people about it go Sheeran
huge shout-outs around Vargas for
producing and directing thank you very
much Ron and support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe in support
simulation our links are below help us
scale our impact to keep growing as well
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in we love
you very much we'll see you soon
peace
[Music]
[Music]